we've been on steroids in this economy
for well over a decade yeah okay very
low interest rates the stimulus checks
at some point if you just continue to do
steroids you're gonna die yeah or once
you get off the steroids for cancer yeah
that too we all know uh liver King who
was here a few months ago when you get
off the steroids just like when you get
off heroin there's going to be a really
rough patch that you're gonna have to
deal with and I think that's essentially
what's
on the uh come up for the economy at
some point but you know does someone
come out tomorrow so we might have to go
through some shitty hard times in order
to feel our best